before we were able to get the road
throughout then they'd say well you
couldn't possibly make that car work and
then just work like hell when you want
to do something new you you have to you
have to apply the physics approach
starting companies like staring at the
abyss and eating glass you have to do
the tough stuff and as well as the
enjoyable stuff it actually matters
whether somebody's good person give a
great product let's if you will buy it
and then the comedy will be successful I
don't ever give up friends are reluctant
to tell you bad things so whether or not
people want to come back or not is kind
of like they can jump on if they want
but they need the spaceship back he
isn't afraid to tackle big challenges in
every interview in every talk and every
sentence he uses passion for what he
does here are Elon Musk's top ten
interviews mentor me Elon
before we were able to get the roads
throughout then they'd say well you can
possibly make that car work and then
when we made the car work they'd say
well nobody going to buy it and then
people bought it and then we announced
the Model S and so many people call
[ __ ] on that it was ridiculous and
and and yet actually the we were able to
bring it to market and then we brought
to market they said well you're never
going to be able to produce with volume
and if did that and then they would say
you will never be able to make a profit
and then we did that in q1 so I'm
hopeful that there's a people observe
that there's a trend here and if it's an
so now that we we have been profitable I
think other manufacturers are more
likely to embark on electric vehicle
projects
I really need to give some thought to
like
I provide advice that would be most
helpful and I'm not sure I've given
enough thought to to that to give you
the best possible answer but I think I
think certainly being focused on
something that you're confident will
have high value to someone else and just
being really rigorous in making that
assessment because people are tend to
natural human tendencies wishful
thinking so a challenge for
entrepreneurs is to say well what's the
difference between really believing new
ideals and sticking sticking to them
versus pursuing some unrealistic dream
that doesn't actually have merit and
it's it's that is it that is a really
difficult thing to to tell you can you
tell the difference between those two
things I know so you need to be sort of
very rigorous in your self self analysis
I think certainly extremely tenacious
and and then just work like hell I mean
you just have to put in you know 80 hour
80 100 hour weeks every week yes
and then matter like that but all those
things improve the odds of success okay
I mean if other people are putting in 40
hour work weeks and you're putting in
100 hour work weeks then even if you're
doing the same thing you know that in
one year you will achieve what they
achieve you will achieve in four months
what it takes them a year to achieve
I do think there's a good good framework
for thinking it is physics you know the
sort of first principles reasoning but
generally that I think they're what what
I mean by that is boil things down to
their fundamental truths and reason up
from there as opposed to reasoning by
analogy through most of our life we we
get through life by reasoning by analogy
which essentially means kind of copying
what other people do with slight
variations and you have to do that
otherwise it's mentally you wouldn't be
able to get through the day
but when you when you want to do
something new you you have to you have
to apply the the physics approach get
physics is really sort of figured out
how to discover new things that are
counterintuitive like quantum mechanics
it's really counterintuitive so I think
I think that's an important thing to do
this may sound like sort of simple
advice but it's hardly anyone does that
and it's incredibly helpful
one does have to be focused on with
short-term and money coming in when
creating a company because otherwise the
company will for die so that the I think
that a lot of times people think like
creating company is going to be fun I
would say it's not it's really not that
fun when there are periods of fun and
there are periods of where it's where
it's just awful and particularly if you
CEO of the company you actually have a
distillation of all the worst problems
in the company there's no point in
spending your time on things that are
going right so you only spend on things
on your time on things that are going
wrong and there are things that are
going wrong that other people can't
can't take care of so you like the worst
you have a filter for the crappiest
problems in the company most pernicious
and painful problem so I wouldn't say
it's it's it I think you have to feel
quite compelled to do it
and have a fairly high pain threshold
and there's a friend of mine who says
like starting companies like staring
into the abyss and eating glass and
there's some truth to that we're staring
into the abyss Pot is that you're going
to be constantly facing the
extermination of the company because
most most startups fail like 90 percent
probably 99% of Starks fail so I so you
that that's the staring in to give this
part you can't constantly saying okay
this if if I don't get this right the
company will die
should be quite correct for quite
stressful and and then the eating glass
part is you've got you've got to do
you've got to do the problems you're
gonna slow you're going to work in the
problems that the company needs you to
work on not the problems you want to
work on and so that the that's you and
I've working on problems that that you
really wish you weren't working on and
so that's the eating glass part then
that goes on for a long time so how do
you keep your focus on the big picture
when you're constantly faced with we
could be out of business in a month
well it's just a very small percentage
of mental energies on the on the big
picture like you know you know where you
generally heading for and and the actual
path is going to be some sort of
zigzagging thing in that direction and
try not to deviate too far from the path
that that you want to be on but you're
going to have to do that some degree but
I don't want to I don't want to diminish
the I mean I think the product the
profit motive is it is a is a good one
if the rules of an industry are properly
set up so there's only fundamentally
wrong with profit in fact profit just
means that people are paying you more
for whatever you're doing then you're
spending to create it that's a good
thing and if you're not if that's not
the case then you'll be out of business
and rightfully so sure you're not adding
enough value
you're being innovative can be very
exciting life a doing business sometimes
requires no persistence and sometimes
could be very boring do you have the
same fun from innovation as from
business running a business
um well I always thought that you'd be
just an innovator engineer instead of a
business owner or runner I mean I'd love
to just do innovation work and just do
engineering but you raise a good point
because you know a lot of life in
general any job there's like you have to
do your chores you know there's no
nobody else it can do that for you
well it's yet to be I think to be
successful at almost anything you can't
if you have to do the tough stuff and as
well as the enjoyable stuff you have to
do the boring stuff as well as the non
boring stuff and if you don't do your
chores then bad things will happen but
if they don't do the things that they
don't like to do then the company will
be in trouble
yeah like you have to basically be like
it's more fun to cook the meal than to
to clean the dishes okay but you need to
clean the dishes we need to get that yes
use your boss exactly
how is the Elan of 2013 different from
the Elan of the zip two days what have
you learned
Waveland well quite quite a lot about a
Scottish you from between out between
then and now I think I've mentioned this
at at winners game I talked itself I
Southwest but I think the I've made
several hiring decisions in the past
which where I valued intellect over
heart and I think that was a mistake and
try to try to adjust accordingly you
know that it actually matters whether
somebody's good person it beyond just
you know goodness itself it right yeah
the ability to attract and motivate
great people is critical to the success
of a company because the company is just
that's a group of people that are
assembled to create a product or service
that's the purpose of a company if you
always forget this elementary truth and
so if you know if you're able to get
great people to join the company and
work together towards a common goal and
and you're sort of have a role and for
the sense of perfection about that goal
then you will end up with a great
product
and if you have a great product let's
people will buy it and then the comedy
will be successful yeah really it's
pretty straightforward really here I
mean yeah that's the reason for it
when you had that third failure in a row
did you think I need to pack this in
never why not I don't ever give up I
mean I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated
always be questioning your your whatever
idea you have not from the standpoint of
reducing confidence in it but more to
make sure it stands up to reason if
something does not stand up to reason
then it is probably false and I think
it's a good idea to solicit negative
feedback from friends in particular
because friends are reluctant to tell
you bad things even if they know it you
know and it doesn't mean that they're
right but they may very well be wrong
but but sometimes they're right and so
if you have a product or service
whatever you want to say you want to ask
your friend said please tell me what you
really think well you know what do you
really think is wrong here and I won't
be offended and you will still be my
friend and then they will tell you
if you look at the jet the trajectory of
space technology and progress the the
pinnacle of that progress was was around
maybe 1969 1970 here were the moon
missions and so we made incredible
progress in the 60s and then we were
able to land moon and then with the
Space Shuttle could only get people to
low-earth orbit now the Space Shuttle is
retired and that's just it I did it
there's no trajectory of improvement
it's a trajectory to nothing so and I
kept thinking that there'd be some plan
to send people to Mars because that's
the obvious next step and the actual
origin of SpaceX is when I was I think
is around 2001 or so and as visiting a
friend of mine they arrest who actually
you may have met but he lives in Palo
Alto now we were college house mates and
he asked me was going to have PayPal and
I said well I always finished in space
and if I didn't think there was anything
I could do in space as an individual so
my initial plan in space was actually to
send to do a small mission to Mars with
where the greenhouse essentially plowed
season dehydrated nutrient gel in a
little greenhouse that would land and
you hydrate the gel and then you grow
the plants and you have this great shot
of green plants in a red background and
that would be the money shot essentially
and and and the people tend to respond
to presidents and superlatives and this
would be the furthest that life's ever
traveled the first life on Mars far as
we know and and that that would give you
excited effort well that would result in
an increased NASA budget and then we
could send people to Mars
because that's you know I think you want
to have a future where you're expecting
things to be better not one where you're
expecting things to be worse so that was
how things started out and then as I
learned more and I went to speaking of
crazy things went to Russia three times
to negotiate a deal to buy a couple of
the largest ICBMs in the Russian fleet
a strange experience how do you even get
into that negotiation uh well you talk
to people who know people
and pretty soon you're talking to the
Russian rocket forces and you know they
turns out Russia's quite quite a
capitalist society and and so I better
but it definitely had some some weird
meetings in places like that I swear
they looked like a sanitarium or
something I don't know it's very odd we
keep going back to the theme of crazy
yeah seriously this place had padded
walls like good why do you padded walls
it was weird and yeah and it's some sort
of Russian guy he was missing a front to
started yelling at me because his friend
one of his front teeth was think it was
like spit flying at me face is that it
was like this really bizarre
right and that wasn't what you thought
I'm gonna build my own rocket yeah I was
probably when I got back from that third
trip was like well I realized that that
the real issue the reason we haven't
advanced in space is because the cost of
space transportation is is become
unaffordable it's got that it's become
more and more expensive to do to do less
and less in space and we really need to
improve the technology of space
transportation so that's why I started
SpaceX but I it may seem odd that I
would saw SpaceX with an expectation of
failure but bear in mind that my initial
thing was to do essentially a
philanthropic mission with zero percent
chance of success from a financial
standpoint so isn't it would have
effectively been a donation to the cause
and so anything better than that is when
looking at the at the Apollo experience
are you concerned that say we land
humans in Mars if they in say 10 15
years and then under Saturn the
excitement is done we've done it and
just go and dress for the next 50 years
like we did with the Polo is that
something that comes
yeah well that's why I think we should
really be setting the goal as the
creation of a self-sustaining
civilization on Mars not simply a
mission to Mars because then we risk you
know it would be awesome and cool and
would be a new high altitude record and
you know great pictures is up but I mean
it would be it just it's just not the
thing that fundamentally changes the
future of humanity and this I mean I
should sort of explain perhaps the
rationale for you know why I think is
important to establish a self-sustaining
colony on Mars because I think you some
people are aware of that but probably
most people aren't and your head you
hear all these rebuttals like under all
these problems on earth that we need to
deal with and shouldn't we focus on that
and the answer is yes I mean our primary
focus should be problems on earth but I
think that there should be some small
amount that's given over to the
establishment of of a colony on Mars and
making life multiplanetary by small
amount I mean some number less than 1%
of our resources so you know it's it's
not as important as as say health care
but it's more important than like say
cosmetics I mean I'm Pro coming up are
in favor of cosmetics I like them
they're great but you know lipstick or
calling on Mars to feel we have
different opinions but I so I so I think
I think we should we should have that
and because the future humanity will
fundamentally bifurcate along the lines
of either single planet species or
multi-planet species and a multi-planet
version of humanity of humanity's future
is going to last a lot longer
we will propagate civilizations the
future far longer if we are multiplying
species than if we are single plant
species and and so it's like planetary
redundancy backing up the biosphere it's
you know it's a we've got all of our
eggs in one basket here we should try to
protect that basket and do everything we
can but but there are some risks that
are just extremely tough
called to mitigate and some which we
will ultimately not be able to mitigate
so it just seems like the right thing to
do and then the question is next
question is what should we do it now or
should we just which we wait for some
point in the future and I think I think
it's the wise move is to do it now
because the window of technology for
this is open and it's the first time
that window has been open in the
four-and-a-half billion year history of
earth we have a long time and and I hope
I certainly hope that the window will be
open here for you know forever but it
may also close and if you look at the
history of Technology in various
civilizations and look at say ancient
Egypt where they're able to build these
incredible giant pyramids and then
they've got how to build permits and
then they couldn't read hieroglyphics or
you look at say Roman civilization and
they were able to build these incredible
aqueducts and roads and then they forgot
how to do that and then in that indoor
plumbing they've got how to input
plumbing you know it's like you know
it's just that there's clearly been a
cycle with with technology and you know
hopefully that that's an upward sloping
sine wave that you know continues on to
be really great in the future but maybe
it doesn't yeah maybe there's some bad
thing that happens and and so for 1% of
our resources we could buy life
insurance for life collectively and I
think that would be a good thing to do
question that has been discussed over
the past couple of days should we be
considering one trips one way only trips
to Mars what's the best approach to
colonize the planet is it but what's
your view it's not socially acceptable
you think people will sign up to do it I
think there's plenty of people who sign
up for a warrior to Mars
but maybe if I could we could have a
show of hands who would consider such an
option I see some not Mariel perhaps
enough for a couple of missions so to
leave it certainly you know I think it's
sort of like is it a one-way mission and
then you die or is it one of my mission
and you get resupplied that's a big
difference
we're for the second option yeah exactly
but I mean I think it's so it ends up
being a moot point because you want to
bring the spaceship back like these
spaceships are expensive okay is there
hard to blows you can't just leave them
there so whether or not people want to
come back or not it's kind of like they
can jump on if they want but they need
the spaceship back thank you
I mean kind of weird like it was like
huge collection of spaceships on Mars
over time really if it's like we're just
in the back and of course we're just in
the back